foreign
statement to the assembled press in
English he'd rehearsed with his lawyer
understand that Russia
we didn't vote for him
for him and he didn't ask us about
starting this war with our closest
Neighbors
23 year old Dimitri Ivanov sentenced to
eight and a half years in jail for
supposedly publishing fake news about
the Russian Armed Forces on his student
telegram Channel
reposts about alleged Russian war crimes
in mariupole and Butcher reposts of
President zielinski's accusations
against Russia
what message do you have to people in
Russia who are scared to speak out
in Russia is a fight with
less care and do what they can
[Applause]
his lawyer clapped outside the courtroom
for the work that she does but she says
it is impossible to bring Witnesses
refugees in Russia from Ukraine for
example to disprove these fake news
charges I I cannot re-traumatize them
with no guarantee of their safety
afterwards and would you therefore be
able do you think to use for example
witness tennis testimony of people who
are in butcher who are now in Europe
video witness testimony in in a Russian
Court they denied us to take as an
Evidence as evidence uh uh even
translated
investigations of New York Times for
example
uh translated reports of Amnesty
International
um
the UN report that Scott didn't take
even that
the only visible signs of protest in
Moscow over the past few weeks were
people leaving flowers here at the
Statue of a famous Ukrainian poet lecia
ukrainca
starting in January when a residential
building in nepro was bombed
people were detained but the flowers
kept coming for weeks after and again on
the anniversary of the war
when people ask why don't the Russian
people protest more well this is why
this is what having no freedom of speech
actually means endless detentions
endless Court hearings the Relentless
one-way March of Russian Justice
so most people do stay silent or they
look the other way because they know
that the state is watching and they know
what that means
Sky News Moscow